there's a fixation on um trying to
address the power differential and
wouldn't it be great if we got the first
x of y right uh now there are a lot of
americans who are kind of impatient with
the first x of y thing
um because it doesn't matter as much as
we thought or hoped or whatever the hell
right um you know there were some people
that thought barack obama present united
states means we're not racist anymore
we're post-racial which by the way we're
probably more racist now than we were
backfired people could you know people
were making the same argument um about
hillary it's like hey first when
president we like show that we all be
over it and then uh you know like uh um
i i don't think that would have fixed it
systemic problems right imagining that
that having an elected representative of
a certain identity and by the way like
i'm for people
of different backgrounds being in
like different seats i mean i i think i
think it's great but but making that
like the
criteria
the criterion that you're using
primarily is is not great and
a lot of americans can sense that the
media in particular has gone overboard
um with this
and one of the byproducts of this is
that it has the potential to
divide the country further
where you have and i'm going to use you
as the proxy
you have like reasonable well-intended
white
people men and women who are generally
aligned with the democratic party on
some things but feel driven out because
there is this implicit like we don't
care about you and your perspective
because you are the powerful in the
power differential equation and all
we're going to do is talk to people who
are from an historically marginalized
group
[Music]
this week on forward did bernie get a
fair shake from the dnc in 2016. why
parents are struggling with the
democratic party
what it's like being a white guy in 2022
in politics this week on forward
and we're back this week there was a bit
of a twitter kerfuffle based upon
something i said that i thought people
already knew when it accepted so let me
rewind uh for a moment a guy named nick
kristoff who works for the new york
times very prominent writer is running
for the governor
of oregon where he grew up where he's
from has a house etc so i saw a story
about how
the insidery democratic secretary of
state had said he is ineligible to run
in the democratic primary because he's
not a resident
and then nick was like hey this is bogus
like i am a resident
and my reaction was
typical democrats uh don't want the
outsider to run and have a chance to
compete so let's ding him and there was
a sense that the democratic secretary of
state obviously close to some of the
other democratic officials in the state
who are running against nick kristoff
again this is a democratic primary
so intra-democratic affair and i i
instinctively thought like that this is
political
and so i
wrote uh hey
no wonder people are losing so much
faith you know in a democratic primary
and then my next thought was that the
democratic party sometimes has a very
anti-lower d democratic impulses where
they kind of like be like no no let's
not listen to whatever the people are
saying let's just do it ourselves or we
know best
and the most prominent example of that
in my mind was kneecapping bernie during
the 2016 presidential nomination right
where hillary clinton was
the favorite the anointed one
of the dnc and so my tweet said
something along the lines of the dnc
should have let hillary and bernie fight
it out fair and square and if they do
that then bernie probably wins and then
bernie probably beats trump democratic
party has some anti-democratic impulses
sometimes and that ended up setting off
uh twitter
you know
part of your quote was do the failings
of the democratic party have something
to do with the rise of trump
question mark sure
will they change tax in 2024 question
mark probably not probably not i think
most people would
so i i didn't know any of this was going
to be controversial you trended on
twitter i love days like that
yeah wake up you chose violence
twitter's going nuts andrew yang's
trending on twitter always a good day
always never not been a good day
in hindsight in the moments kind of
tough always fun though again like i
thought this was objective documented
fact that the dnc kneecap bernie at
every turn i mean donna brazile's book
came out and said yeah that's what went
on it was documented fact she had to
walk it back but it seems pretty
documented that hillary had at least a
slight advantage at worst here i thought
the full story was that the dnc was
running low on money and the hillary
clinton campaign
gave them like an allowance and then in
in return the dnc was like yeah the fix
is in that is the bigger allegation here
i mean that that stuff must be backed up
so you know it's pretty
i was trying to do some research on this
like see what we got i'm not an expert
the story's all over the map it does
seem
while hillary did that
it also appears that the dnc
theoretically offered the same type of
influence to other candidates as
well they said hey bernie you give us
money too yeah if anyone else wants
money we would do the same that was
anyway i i look obviously anyone
watching objectively was like yeah she's
like the shadow primary the shadow
primary yeah so i
i didn't think this was necessarily no
okay so the dnc putting their thumb on
the scale for hillary to me
uncontroversial
was it dispositive in the result like
you know if you just had a truly fair
objective process does bernie beat
hillary that's arguable
so the fact that i was like hey he
probably wins like you could take issue
with that statement and i'd be like yeah
yeah like and you know i i do
feel like bernie shocked everyone with a
level of energy around his campaign he
it felt very organic that that was part
of the contrast where bernie had the
people's energy and then hillary kind of
had that corporate energy so that if you
take issue and be like hey hillary would
have won anyway it's like okay we can
you know that's fine um bernie beating
trump i feel like that's
very
i'm confident in that estimation that
that piece of it doesn't feel terribly
controversial to me either like trump if
you remember going into that 2016 race
people really were not excited about
trump and a lot of people thought it was
inconceivable that he would it would
have been interesting because i think he
would have been painted even more of a
socialist than he is now by fox news
and i'll be interested to see how that
plays out but i agree that's definitely
a strong argument that
he would have had a shot uh so it got me
thinking about this entire like
anti-like democratic impulse
feeling i have around the democratic
party where there is like this corporate
lair
they represent the establishment
and then there are
people who want various things that are
on the outside looking in
and i think that dynamic will continue
to plant in the democratic party in
large part because there are
very
large corporate interests who
are right there with the democratic
party saying uh especially you know some
of their attached media organizations
the fact that this ended up lighting a
bit of a firestorm was genuinely
surprising to me but i guess that just
shows where i am this opens a number of
questions and i want to ask them all
cause who got mad here is either burners
or like
yes andrew this is obvious like screw
you like don't try and jump on our train
now you miss this boat and then folks
that were saying
you're wrong andrew or this isn't the
case um so start with the burners piece
tell me about your support
i mean i have a good sense of it but
tell the world about your support for
bernie sanders and your relationship
there i remember in 2016 watching a
bernie rally or speech uh on tv
and saying
yeah this is right i don't disagree with
anything he's saying and then i thought
well i should
support him in some way so i sent in a
donation
and then
when he lost i then said okay i guess
i'll vote for hillary which i did
um so i supported bernie during the
primary
and
saw that he was mistreated and
kneecapped and and the rest of it
um and
you know i wasn't
um raging in the streets about it i was
like oh yeah here's the dnc
you know doing their thing and then he's
like i guess it's hillary i guess you
know like that that was my
um attitude it was sadness and
frustration
over bernie's treatment but clearly
thought hillary would be a much better
president than trump so right now that's
what i want but you had said a number of
times when you ran for president that
bernie in some ways inspired your run
um
am i right and saying i'm remembering
that and like but both policy wise and
then movement wise and the energy around
it and it's one of the reasons one of
many reasons you were exploring a run in
2020 is that right oh yeah it was
invigorating and uplifting and i again i
agreed with everything he was saying so
i was like wow there are these really
big deep
problems that the american people are
trying to figure out how to answer and
so and most of our policies like at
least i remember being in the room we
were very spiritually aligned with
bernie's intent we just want to make
things better for people right like
bernie wants to make things better for
people i want to make things better for
people you know i think people at every
part of the political spectrum want to
make things better for people i just
talked to a guy who
surveyed democrats and republicans about
what they want most of it's the same
yeah not great it's like there's a
slight
reorganization but the top five goes
something like more jobs
better schools for kids
better access to health care reduce
crime
like in in some order so things aren't
going well our institutions are
underperforming we're 28th in the world
and declining at most basic quality of
life measurements right and the two
parties are not genuinely arguing over
who can actually deliver better results
for people it's like an ideological
struggle
it's one reason why i think bernie does
beat trump is because
bernie
seems and is
for the people
not corrupt
uh sincere would like really have shaken
things up
in dcs president that's what most people
want at this point he was similar to you
you guys had a lot in common that you
were both laser focused on the issues
like did not get caught up in a lot of
like the petty spats and things like
that and he never has his whole career
generally speaking he's pretty much
laser focused on
for him it was vermont or various
aspects of his platform
i mean when bernie i remember this like
bernie had a heart attack middle race we
thought he was the world thought he was
dropping out i was gonna ha i thought we
were gonna have to and like kudos to him
like a freaking warrior like he had a
heart attack back on the trail like
three days later whatever it was um but
i mean it wasn't just us the press as
well we're saying that you know one of
the biggest beneficiaries here would be
andrew of course because we had a lot of
similar
both principles and audiences and vibes
and things like that now in the
presidential
you endorse biden
and
i would say i think rational human
beings at that point where like this
race is over you were lining up but
there were plenty of burners online that
are probably the same way the yang gang
would react if bernie endorsed biden and
we had already lost right
um but
that like rationality doesn't always
play well on twitter or online or with
rabid fan bases so thoughts on maybe
talk a little bit more about
that endorsement process what that went
through your mind because i think the
whole time you were more of a bernie guy
than a biden guy you know yeah i was
hoping the whole time that bernie came
out for universal basic income or some
version and i i'd communicated in
various ways like look you guys come out
for ubi i'm there i'm coming early yeah
yeah and bernie for whatever reason was
not a fan of universal base can come at
that time like logically would be bernie
i don't think you had said if any i
believe you said if any contender down
the stretch here comes out yeah yeah it
was great it was clear as day i was like
look just kidding
and by the way the end game will fall in
line too you know yeah let's do it
that's what they're for joe wins
michigan and at that point the
numbers made it such that it would be
nearly impossible he swept essentially
super tuesday right it was like yeah so
i was like okay this this race is
is effectively over and so let let me
line up and try and get trump out
because that was to me the focus right
which i respect it's one of the things
and we'll talk about this probably more
on the podcast but one of the things
makes you in my opinion a great a person
i respect and it also makes you frankly
like a
less effective traditional politician in
the sense that you
you know what it means to be a leader in
this like you value leadership and like
what what a lot of comes with what and
having been in leadership roles what
comes to leadership is frankly the guy
or gal has to make the hard decision no
one likes right like the hard decision
there is like yeah
line up behind the guy be if like if the
greater good is or greater decision or
where this country needs to go is a line
up behind who can beat donald trump
this is the decision a leader needs to
make and not worry about his own
political career right and you to be
fair you didn't call the biden team and
ask for favors you didn't say hey what
are you going to give me you didn't you
just did it um
and i think
a traditional maybe more selfish
politician would be like hey joe what do
you got for me i'm going to make this
endorsement and you did it because that
was the right thing to do what a leader
should do yeah when joe called me i said
no so uh you know it was a pretty shitty
way to try and get stuff that's true
i forgot about that yeah i did well part
of it too and this is what i think what
you're suggesting is that i'm not a
terribly ideological fellow you know if
you put me in a seat at a particular
moment in time be like okay like what's
the maximal
uh value to be had it's like the maximum
value at that point was to try and do
everything i could to in my opinion get
trump out and if joe's gonna be the
nominee then let me get to work right
and uh try and bring people together as
quickly as i can
um
so that's what i did uh right now with a
forward party i feel the same way it's
like what's the most maximally
useful thing i can do and it's try and
give people
real choices and just face facts of this
duopoly is going to ruin us that that
there is
no
massive transformation that's going to
emerge from these institutions oh
actually i take it back but there are
negative transformations that can emerge
from these institutions
we're not going to see
like the the
wave of
positive transformation innovation like
that that's not happening i've been
writing about this talking about how
basically
sticking to principles or like setting
your identity around one policy or
position is now the norm and that's how
a lot of people are building what i call
identity brands have people identify
with that position and identify with
that person but also it's like they're
they're becoming famous politically
speaking um because of this
and it prevents compromise
but it also is somewhat politically
effective right because you you can
build these movements and become a force
and be a pain in a thorn in someone's
side whatever it is
you have you've staked out a few like
key principles but generally speaking to
your point you're not an ideological
fellow with your exact words you are
you listen to reason frankly you
change your mind when new evidence is
presented to the contrary to me that's
good leadership i think that's what
rational human beings do but literally
the press have called you a lightweight
because of that right or they've called
you i mean god knows what like a lot of
things does that frustrate you have you
ever thought like oh maybe i should just
like dig my heels in because it's going
to be better
to accomplish a political goal than
what may be true to your principles or
who you are naturally as a human no i
tend not to think in those terms but i i
see the pressures that other political
figures are under which is
that like you said you stake something
out and then you just become so here is
what most politicians would have done in
my shoes i think yeah is like you run
for president on universal basic income
and then just become the ubi guy yes and
then you just run around and say hey i'm
going to
stake this out no i happen to believe in
universal basic income and that we need
to make it happen i started an
organization humanity forward that's
working very hard to try and move us
um in in that direction
i
didn't have that much of an interest in
saying like hey i'm going to be mr ubi
forever which by the way would have in
my opinion
made me pretty well liked we got
pressure
the reason why i didn't naturally want
to do it was because
i saw the political
pressures for it and against it and i
thought well andrew yang running around
saying ubi ubi
i don't believe
really changes that equation in a way
that would make it more likely to happen
now some people might disagree but this
was my read
i think we're better served by having
professional lobbyists working it and
not leading with andrew yang andrew yang
you know just saying look your
constituents love this different people
love this the political incentives are
for you to become a symbol and then
we're like oh i can like make currency
by being the symbol then you just become
that symbol
i think a lot of figures get stuck in
various ways
i'm more of a human being
i suppose it'd be like oh
you know like let me try and solve the
problem let me genuinely try and solve
the problem and to me solving the
problem means reforming these
institutions
and i'm really pumped to be doing it
because the folks who are working on
reforming these institutions are
noble and principled and well intended
and they need help
so
if i can do that then there's a much
higher chance
of these original goals
actually
being achieved that the issue is that
people
don't want a whole lot of flexibility or
adaptation
in their political figures you know it's
like they'll be singing version the same
tune for years and years and years which
i don't hate right you know it's like
you you appreciate it
[Music]
all right guys it's 2022 how is your
mental health what is preventing you
from achieving your goals how's your
stress is there anything interfering
with your happiness folks i want you to
check out betterhelp.com
yang because at betterhelp.com you can
assess your needs and match with a
licensed professional therapist so it's
not like a crisis line is a secure safe
and private online professional
counseling environment it's super
convenient you can start communicating
in under 48 hours you just get matched
on there super simple again you can
basically just send a message to your
counselor anytime so that's texting
little chats or you can do video
conferences which i would do once a week
and you get timely thoughtful responses
plus you can schedule weekly phone or
video sessions it's pretty freaking
great so whether you've got depression
stress anxiety relationship issues
sleeping trouble anger family conflicts
grief you name it
anything you share is confidential and a
licensed professional can help you and
guide you through this securely online
convenient professional affordable i
want you to check out better help so
here's the deal
andrew and i want you to start living a
happier life today and as a listener
you're going to get 10 off your first
month by visiting our sponsor at
betterhelp.com yang join over 1 million
people who have taken charge of their
mental health again that's betterhelp
help
dot com slash yang
when you had finished
your presidential race in 2020 if i was
keeping my same political marketing hat
on and i'm curious if you would agree
this is what i would have told you to do
i would have told you to you lean into
your com your identity brand 100 so you
lean in you're still the cash relief
free money guy you're an outsider and
you're tech forward opposite donald
trump asian man who likes math right i
would have
pressed you and folks did press you to
do to get a job in the biden cabinet
ideally in a tech role right that's
totally totally on brand and in a vague
role that had low expectations maybe a
new role maybe ahead of like the
existing roles were science and
technology but some sort of like
chief innovation officer or secretary of
the future or something where you could
just go around the country and be the
free money
forward thinking
guy and then you would have this brand
you'd own this lane
never would have advised you to run for
mayor or anything else until
it was like uh probably president again
right and you'd probably have the same
probably had bernie's fate if you will
like a better run round two but still
been in your lane and not able to
broaden out but i think that influence
would be like politically powerful in
various ways i don't know about you i
had that in my ear from a whole bunch of
our supporters at least the more
political traditional ones did you get
that as well or do you have people
giving you
this type of advice over and over i i
did hear that sometimes yeah to me
you're too much of an operator to evo
ever want to be in a lane like that you
know where you're like well the
problem's actually duopoly it's not the
cash really there's plenty of people who
do cash relief now like i've solved that
like like awareness problem right um
and that's the hardest part where you um
you become this type politician it's
very difficult to get out of it and
you lose some stuff and you get out of
it too you have to blow some things up
you have to take a step back to go to
forward wherever it is right yeah again
i don't really think in those terms it's
just like hey how can i yeah add the
most value and solve them you know solve
the biggest problems i can during the
time so if it was waffling around dc
pretending to have impact and be like i
you know like did this i was on that
like it would have sucked i don't think
that would have been genuine uh but i
did get advice from people who were
thinking in terms of like democratic
politics yeah oh yeah i understood it
but i also thought we'd hate it you know
yeah but i think people would have
recognized it as someone inauthentic too
that's the biggest part of it you have
to remain authentic to yourself we hated
the process of looking at the cabinet
roles yeah it was very
distasteful and innervating like it
didn't make me think like oh i really
wanna i can't wait for this yeah just
like oh god you guys like and this is a
microcosm of why i think people are
frustrated in that like my glimpse into
that process was like whoa
like it was like you get in there and
then all of a sudden it's like
democratic jockeying for
positions of this and that uh you know
and i'm i'm seeing it with so this is
not a knock who the hell knows but like
you know marty walsh who was the mayor
of boston became the secretary of labor
in dc and now the word is that he's
going to leave to go come back and run
for
you know
for a position in massachusetts think
governors i don't know something right
um but it just really paints a picture
that these big deal dc positions
are just another seat
like you do it and you're like oh now
i'm gonna do this like there's like this
game of musical chairs and then you'll
like talk about the impact you had while
you were in that seat yeah so that was
the vibe i got and it wasn't a good
feeling we talked to a lot of people
that were in let's call it senior roles
in the office of science and technology
the department of labor things like this
and they would they were talking down to
you and me like and i wrote this paper
and i did this white paper i did this a
lot of white papers frankly but like i
don't know i never heard any of this i
don't think the average american would
have a clue i mean the average american
has no idea that the office of science
and technology policy exists this isn't
helpful at all so i mentioned two parts
of your tweet that were interesting one
was the bernie piece which we kind of
just outlined but the other one was
criticizing democrats in the election in
general and i want to ask you this i
know you're going to think that's
ridiculous but i really just want your
thoughts i think there's a challenge
there's like this inherent signal
sometimes when you criticize the
democratic party you're inherently still
okay with what republicans are doing so
a lot of democrats when you criticize
the party like you've seen what the
republicans are doing when they're
actual racists like how dare you
criticize the democrats and the
republicans are this bad
how do you think we navigate that
because i struggled this too and i'm
like god the damn sucked they're like
well the republicans are awful why
aren't you complaining about that i was
like i don't know we've kind of known
the republicans are god awful for a long
time to have to keep hammering it like
i'm worried about the my team i don't i
don't know i don't know not that it's
your team per se anymore but
thoughts on how we um
are able to criticize the dems without
saying we're okay with the far right
that is the knee-jerk response
on both sides like have you seen the
other side um so so this is a segue into
a couple of articles that you and i were
reading and talking about this week
which were these two parents moms
who
criticized school closures in their
communities one in cleveland one in
oakland and then just got attacked
as being
trumpists essentially i think yeah or
people who were anti-science
anti-teachers anti yeah like high
maintenance white parents was
what this woman said she was accused of
being called in the atlantic yes so
these parents were negatively impacted
by school closures which any parent can
tell you it's a bit of a disaster where
your kid eventually just gives up on
remote schooling because remote
schooling is this the teacher
logs on for remote schooling like 15
minutes a week and if that seems like an
exaggeration if you talk to enough
parents like you know that that's not
unusual the response from
various activists are to just respond
very negatively to criticism but the
democratic party just takes criticism
very very poorly even when the stated
goals
uh of the party aren't being met where
if you look at who is going to be
negatively impacted by school closures
you know who gets it the worst
children of color who can least afford a
year away from school
working class parents who need to have a
place to bring their kids the most
vulnerable get hurt the most so if you
prioritize those people you'd be like
you know what school stay open hell or
high water
and that was not the priorities that the
priorities were the teachers unions and
so then when you say hey this is messed
up then the the right response in some
ways would be like oh yeah like we
really need to get on this because you
know like we we actually live to our
values are like our stated priorities
um but because politics has become so
tribal
uh criticism gets taken as like an
attack from the other team even if as
these two moms were they were both like
hey i'm on this team like i've been a
democrat for a million years and the
data shows that this issue
was a bigger deal in the virginia race
than quote-unquote critical race theory
yep um and as a parent with a child in
public school whose school was closed
for better part of a year
parents are so
angry about this
and a lot of parents that had the
ability
um you know one of the the moms in these
articles
eventually after it sounds like two
years of struggle of eventually um sent
a child to private school
charter school yeah or charter school or
private school felt really bad about it
but the
repercussions to these kids of remote
schooling or lack of schooling i mean
it's going to last for years maybe a
generation
there's going to be a reckoning around
like this is going to be such a signal
failure for
anyone who's associated with it
and the sooner the democratic party
realizes that there are a lot of parents
that feel this way because this is a
political
disaster yes for dems particularly if
you're in an area that is anywhere
close to being tightly contested so we
talk about a lot of articles but this
one guys i cannot encourage you to read
it more it was jarring the article is
called why i soured on democrats we'll
put it in
the link of this episode it starts off
with this woman talking about how much
of a card-carrying dem she is
she's like i registered a vote like
before you can possibly register
i'm like i've lost friends over how much
i hate donald trump i am i go to
protests and not just the black lives
matter protest i've been protesting for
decades like i am a
i'm the stereotypical like female
democratic voter and she's like i don't
know who to vote for because the
democratic party has betrayed me and she
she talks in detail about how difficult
it is to have a three-year-old and a
five-year-old have two working parents
and get them through remote school and
like for me i don't have kids and so yet
um
and i've always heard like i've always
been like kind of you and i joke like oh
yeah that's gotta be hell right but then
when you read about it like that is
awful
awful and the thought to me of be paying
taxes a lot of taxes you're
taking half your income in taxes
and the school just not be open
and so now i'm what
infuriating and the only thing they can
do is vote and they're like i have trump
or the party that's supposed that's in
power not doing anything i don't know
what to do
and
and this was the quote that stuck with
me and read to you said she said none of
this has shaken my support for the
democratic agenda which i still endorse
wholesale which is interesting
what i've lost is my trust that the
party is truly motivated to act in the
interests of those they claim to serve
how can i get excited about universal
pre-k proposals for example when k-12 is
in shambles and that to me just hit it a
nail on the head right there like i'm
still like like the policies the
democratic party yes let's go
but
the democratic party didn't do any of it
and so then you're stuck between rock
and hard place like trump sucks and the
democrats are supposed to help us also
suck so
forward party it is the this is the
fundamental challenge that the
democratic party will not reckon with
uh
which is that
a lot of the institutions aren't
actually delivering the value that
they're purported to
and it's
clearer now with schools during the era
of kovid
but it was true of the school's
pre-covet where if you look at the value
that
parents and families were getting out of
the investments in education
it wasn't what you what you'd expect or
deserve uh you know we've been failing
parents writing left for for a long time
and this is one reason why the duopoly
is so toxic is because the democrats say
look we're going to say we're for a
bunch of things
and whether or not our schools or
hospitals or government or services
actually deliver the values we say
irrelevant the republican party will
come along and say hey
we don't believe in a lot of this stuff
or these institutions it's wasteful it's
inefficient let's cut cut cut let's cut
taxes et cetera and there needs to be a
third way where it's look we want to use
your tax dollars efficiently to deliver
resources that are at a very high value
make it effective efficient these
schools are going to be great your
healthcare is going to be great your
roads are going to be great like we're
going to actually kick ass
and right now there's no competitive
pressure for government to deliver you
either have these kind of slumping
bureaucracies that everyone's getting
fed up with and then democrats will make
lofty promises about what those
bureaucracies will deliver most of which
aren't true and the republicans will
just be like look they're full of
and then you know like that that's the
contest of ideas that we're stuck with
um so what you would need is a third way
where it's like look it turns out we all
want the same things we want
decent schools for our kids and a
thriving economy full of jobs we
actually want and
decent health care and
low crime and high public safety and
like you know a positive environment
like again democrats and republicans
like want these things
um just the the question is how can we
actually start delivering in a time when
the media conversation is not around
outcomes it's around drama politics
perception social media
the back and forth of the day again
we're 28th in the world on
public education
uh clean drinking water infant mortality
life expectancy etc etc with a down
arrow
[Music]
it's 2022
folks and if you are a small business
owner like we are you are busy enough as
it is you don't have time to deal with
the hassle of going to the post office
and i want to talk to you about
stamps.com because with stamps.com you
can skip the trip never waste another
dollar or minute stamps.com lets you
print official postage right from your
computer so you can spend less time at
the post office and more time doing the
thing you're supposed to be doing like
you know running your business so
stamps.com saves you time money and
stress for more than 20 years stamps.com
has been indispensable for over 1
million businesses including ours they
give you access to all the post office
and ups shipping services you need right
from your computer so whether you're
sending invoices you got your side
hustle etsy shop or you're like a
full-blown warehouse shipping out
hundreds of orders stamps.com will make
your life easier and all you need is a
computer with a standard printer no
special supplies or equipment it's
pretty freaking easy you're up and
running in minutes printing official
postage for any letter any package
anywhere you want to send so here's the
deal save money and time this year with
stamps.com sign up with promo code yang
for a special offer that includes a four
week trial free postage and a digital
scale no long term commitments or
contracts just go to stamps.com folks we
love this stuff click the microphone at
the top of the page enter code yang get
your four week trial right now
this is the
switch that has to happen and this
mess with the schools is waking up a lot
of dems to the fact that look
um
this should not be as ideological as it
is i mean one thing that bill maher just
put out that you just sent me was that
democrats dramatically overestimate the
chances of kovan putting you in the
hospital and it's not like you know the
actual number is one to five percent
right yeah some of that um but it's not
like we think 20 of the people are dying
it's they think like 50 plus percent of
people are dying and 70 a party thinks
it's over 20
of people are dying yeah so so this to
me has to be the the message that these
moms are finding out yeah is that the
democrats imagine
that they're the party of facts
and science
uh and then the republicans are
uh troglodytes and you know like
ignorant and the rest of it um but then
when you start digging it turns out that
the democrats are actually tribal
uh and ideological
in the same way as anyone else and
that's not a knock it's just you know
everyone's somewhat tribal uh but then
if someone like this mom in cleveland
raise their hand and be like hey i'm a
member of the tribe and like you know
the these facts aren't lining up then
they'll just get hammered down like
instead of you know so like because then
they'll be like hey turns out you're not
on our team or what not yes and they're
all these people embedded within the
democratic party who actually have
similar points of view who fear the
hammering down they know if they say
these things and that's what we're going
to get to now
which is
your experience as someone who is
something of a convert to the democratic
party that there is a sense that some
people
some people's experiences are more valid
than others if you are
let's say in your case like a straight
white dude or in this author's case like
a white mom
then you're not allowed to criticize or
talk and that if you do
then you're going to be personally
attacked it's a really deep point and
it's it's it's his she's thought where
do you go right and the challenge is
on the presidential level which a lot of
us
we hold a president is a different
election right we hold them as like
almost god-like essentially in terms of
our leaders and what we look up to and
blame things on and that's
a lot of like research on that too
it's a combination of whether it's
virtue signaling or
the right mouth piece um in terms of who
can say what and what can be said and
i'm curious your thoughts on this
because my hesitation of ever getting
into politics is that i'm like socially
aligned with democrats i think the
democrats generally have the right
policies on a lot of things some things
on the republican side i think you know
i like capitalism more than um i do
socialism or other socialism other
things but um
i've hesitated because i don't think the
democratic party loves straight white
men
um and even when i was telling talking
to you about running
before like before i met you when we
first started i was like how do you beat
donald trump i was like thinking i had
to be an outsider i had to be someone
who was young i thought they had to be
male i thought they had to have the
balance to the trump male energy but i
also thought they had to be diverse
coming from the democratic party to get
through that primary you've talked about
this a bit with john mcwhorter but why
are democrats we're obsessed with
identity i have some thoughts on it too
but we care a lot about the messenger
over the message at times you lived that
i think
both the pros and cons of that john
described it in his book woke racism
which you should check out and check out
my convo with uh with john um if you
haven't seen it he says that there's a
certain subset of the democratic party
that is obsessed
with the power differential
um so the power differential typically
is framed as white black or whites have
the power blacks do not and so whites
need to uh try and address this through
various behaviors that john argues don't
actually address the fundamental
problems that people care about it's
just you know sort of a strange
behavioral layer but the other power
differentials that people are concerned
about um are male female straight part
of the lgbtq yeah right yes and so
taking a figure like you um you are
all of the quote unquote like uh
positives and the power differentials
because you're a straight white male
also in your case uh you have the sins
of being tall
handsome
[Laughter]
i'm the devil incarnate the rest of it
so
if you frame everything in power
differential then it's like well someone
like you
then any success you achieve is uh
because
you are who you are and it had nothing
to do with your
uh actions character or work ethic like
you know
it's just you know you just fell out of
bedroom right yeah um and are super
successful um and
the asian guy
um occupies like a nebulous place in
this uh in this framework
because if you look at andrew yang you
think okay um straight male
asian
and then you're like where are asians in
the
power differential right um and the
answer is
it is whatever is convenient to you
minority behind the scenes but now we're
putting in front of the scenes if we can
but the asians are known as a convenient
minority in democratic politics so
they're not a minority when they want
some message and they are
people of color when they uh when it's
politically convenient yeah so i was
interested obviously as a candidate how
it would be received
um and i think that it turns out that um
that the quote unquote benefits of being
a minority um did not include
me
like there wasn't this like oh like you
know look what this person must have
overcome as a son of immigrants like
that that stuff all went out the window
which i'm
more or less cool with and i think a lot
of it too is the persona i have which is
i'm not someone who
is going to be leading with like look at
all the i've overcome kind of stuff
like that that's not my jam i'm more
like okay let's get done you know
let's uh
operate um and one of the major reasons
why i wouldn't fall into the negative
side of this power differential the like
less powerful side right is because uh
the
perception was like well he's a business
guy he's a tech bro he's uh this or that
but but to your point in the
presidential primary we've discussed
this yeah there were half a dozen or
more
straight wine men who ran that never got
the time of day in the presidential race
many of whom
we spoke with personally you and i and
we liked and thought well of and thought
would make fine presidents
one guy who completely got short shift
joe sesdak yeah great guy
press completely ignored him people
watching this right now are like who
yeah you look up uh joe sesdak um
michael bennett great guy
uh john hickenlooper the one i thought
that actually had the full package was
john hickenlooper where that he was an
entrepreneur
uh he started what's the goose island
beer whatever the beer company is um
ran it himself and then became governor
like has business political experience
um
and real and actually is
like there were some and i'm going to
leave them nameless not fair but there
were plenty of
where i'm at like the world doesn't
we're not clamoring for more straight
white dudes in politics like we have
that voice we have that perspective
right i'm not that's not the problem
well this to me is one of the dangers
good is that if you look at the straight
white dudes in politics uh the media
organizations of the democratic side do
not want to elevate
this set of figures yes they
will accept like the folks who are
already kind of you know emblazoned in
the public consciousness like uh bernie
or joe right but and why is that you
think is it because of
representation
yeah
there's a there's a fixation
there's a fixation on
um trying to address the power
differential and wouldn't it be great if
we got the first
x of y right uh now there are a lot of
americans who are kind of impatient with
the first x of y thing
um because it doesn't matter as much as
we thought or hoped or whatever the hell
right um you know there were some people
that thought barack obama present united
states means we're not racist anymore
we're post-racial which by the way we're
probably more racist now than we were
backfired people could you know people
were making the same argument um about
hillary it's like hey person when
president we like show that we all be
over it and then uh
you know like uh um i i don't think that
would have fixed it like like that
imagine systemic problems right
imagining that that having an elected
representative of a certain identity and
by the way like i'm for people of
different backgrounds being in
like different seats i mean i i think i
think it's great but but making that
like the
criteria
the criterion that you're using
primarily is is not great and
a lot of americans can sense that the
media in particular has gone overboard
um with this
and one of the byproducts of this is
that it has the potential to
divide the country further
where you have and i'm going to use you
as the proxy
you have like reasonable well-intended
white people men and women who are
generally aligned with the democratic
party on some things but feel driven out
because there is this implicit like we
don't care about you and your
perspective because you are the powerful
in the power differential equation and
all we're going to do is talk to people
who are from an historically
marginalized group because we i live
this both personally and through you
right on this campaign but also um i
want to share this with everybody we
live this actually
with each other i don't know if you
remember this story um
it was really early on i just started on
the campaign and i was
we'd go into like our first couple
meetings and i'd make these little
one-off comments i didn't even realize i
was making i'd be like
uh we'd talk about your campaign or i'd
talk about the campaign and be like well
that's if we if we do okay or that's
before we get a real campaign manager or
we get a real xyz or like kind of caveat
what we're doing
and you
got really mad and in my opinion
justifiably so you're like stop
second guessing this caveatting like we
got to go in guns blazing we are
confident we're setting the world on
fire this is a vision we have to get
people on board we can't give them crap
show the cracks in our in our faith in
this because we don't believe how
they're going to believe which is
logical
but and then it got to a point where i
was really like proactively working on
it and i was still it up like
you and you would notice it make you
more mad you're like i've asked you six
times to do this and i remember i sat
you down probably like it took me a
while figured i'm like dude here's the
deal
my whole life
i naturally come at it
trying to be as humble as humanly
possible when i go to a meeting because
i come off as a you
don't look at this caucus look at this
um who's where'd he go
that like that that's right and so
like and you but then you told me like
and i was like i think for you having
watching you like
and this is up too but like as an
asian guy people think you're timid or
shy or not not sure of yourself and
gonna stand there quietly and let people
walk over you which is a
stereotype so you go the opposite you're
like bang extreme and when you have if
you say the same thing that i would say
it comes off 10 times different and i've
learned that
the hard way because one time in ohio i
gave your stump speech at like a
democratic event like the basically word
for word stump awful crash and burn
could not do it the opposite of donald
trump is an asian guy who likes math
doesn't sound as cool
it sounds a little offensive coming from
me
it did not go well um
identity matters um and like and um i'm
not there's systems around us that are
creating those perceptions and realities
did you feel the need to be more
confident in yourself and your vision
because you were asian or was that
something you had growing up to or
something you felt more in politics some
thoughts on on that piece well certainly
on the campaign front people i knew were
going to take their cues from us and so
if i come in and people like oh he's not
serious then you know they're not going
to tell their friends because they're
like this isn't going to go anywhere in
terms of my upbringing and the rest of
it um i was one of the only
asian kids in my public school
uh so i felt like my masculinity was in
question all the time i'd also skipped a
grade so that that made it shorter i was
like scrawnier and shorter and like that
the rest of it uh i had a chip on my
shoulder i got in a lot of fights as a
kid um and so then when i i lost most of
them and then when
i got to like age 17 i started going to
the gym
and so i became like an angry
weightlifting asian guy who drank
protein shakes and the rest of it yeah
you know these guys yeah if you went to
the yeah spot you bro and you went if
you went to the i liked them they played
basketball mostly too yes
i you know i did that
and so was that in some ways a response
to
challenges to my masculinity growing up
a hundred percent yeah it's a phenomenon
that a lot of
asian guys are familiar with or if you
go to the gym you see the the asian
dudes
over there
it's
i mean i'm very and we can do a whole
episode of this i'm very very passionate
about um manhood and understanding
um
i think most of the some of the biggest
problems in our society are caused by
weak men insecure men like if you want
we want to help women like like helping
men be less shitty is a really good way
to wait a place to start frankly because
a lot right um what men go through as
kids is uh like in how they define their
masculine he's a big part of that i did
musicals right so i had to do sports to
balance that out because i like to sing
i like to play saxophone you better do
some sports though i had
and then i didn't fit in either right so
here's i've never said this out loud but
i'm i'm curious it's like if there's an
acceptance in the democratic party that
the straight white male is the
root of all evil and power like that's
the bastion of uh there's a subset of
the democratic party that would agree
with that right right that's that's the
problem right
i don't i don't know if vilifying all of
them is the right
strategy i'm going to say it's the wrong
strategy right
[Music]
so i want to i want to say this but
there's a scene in the dark knight
batman when um
there's a i think his reporter or it's a
lawyer finds out that bruce wayne's
taking an accounting consultant yeah
something like that and he goes to
morgan freeman who's the ceo of wayne
enterprises he finds out that they're
spending money on the batmobile and
things like that and the quote is he
basically says he tries to blackmail
he's like i want 10 million dollars
every year for the rest of my life
because i'm gonna expose this is and
morgan friedman looks in the eye and
says
so you think your client who's one of
the wealthiest and most powerful men in
the world
is secretly a vigilante who spends his
nights beating criminals to a pulp with
his bare hands
and your plan is to blackmail this
person
good luck
and that to me is what i feel with now
doing wrong there are plenty like there
are plenty of i've worked with them on
wall street there are plenty of white
straight men
in power that are doing shitty things or
turning a blind eye or proactively
keeping people of color and the
disadvantage down but there are also a
good number of folks that fit that same
old that are trying to help and if you
believe that all the power and wealth
and energy whatever the hell is in that
one
type of person
we'd probably want some of them to be on
our team if they want to be um that's
not easy like someone like me like i got
a lot to learn right and i'm well i i
would agree with this you know um that
you should take people's individuals in
my opinion and so if you meet someone
and they are a straight white dude
thinking like oh i
will immediately dismiss this person
because they can't understand what it
means i mean the other thing is like
people have been through things that you
just can't imagine like there could be a
straight white person whose
parents died when he was three years old
you know i mean like like you know they
they're different sources of pain
beyond
just identity-based
adversity
so
i you know
to me it would be ridiculous to
think
we can
build anything and then but we're going
to dismiss people of a certain
background right like that just doesn't
make any sense to me that
uh and it probably wouldn't be effective
but what what you're saying is also true
in that
if you want good things to happen
um you'd want people
who are not just willing friends and and
uh parts of the movement but also people
that might have some resources to bring
to bear that might have some
relationships to bring in skills to
whatever it is right and that's my my
fear and i want to ask you about what we
think we should do here because i what
i'm seeing is with my let's call it my
my white straight my male friends
they're drifting away from the
democratic party they're they're
aligning up with this woman who wrote
the art piece in the atlantic or they're
shifting closer and closer to the
republican party and most of them have
always been democrats
and definitely socially liberal
and sympathetic and empathetic to
the progressive movement their whole
life you know and i had a group thread
about just asking folks hey like
basically how are you feeling about
these types of topics and the quotes i
got from my friends or what they feel is
that i'll give you some quotes i feel
like i'm racist i'm assumed to be a
racist um as a white person i feel like
i have to speak second always which you
know for better word these are not to
say my quotes that the meritocracy
isn't relevant so you are
the reason you are successful any amount
of success you've had is because you are
white male and straight
and a lot of them was you can't say that
they're afraid of saying anything
because and i am too and even talking
about now like afraid of stepping on a
land mine and um saying the wrong thing
and it's it's hard because if
you're if we want
let's call it straight white dudes like
myself to help more you got to let them
up a little bit learn from their
mistakes and move on right you know
right as opposed to oh you said the
wrong thing you're racist
go away you're not part of this movement
and then they either grovel the rest of
their life to try and get back in or
they go right to the arms of trump um
or or what they most likely do
is they keep their heads down in various
public settings
they do nothing
yeah yeah they they you know they send
their kids to private school and chill
they yeah they don't give a no it's
the quote it's like the only thing
necessary for evil to prevail is for
good men to do nothing and it's the
biggest
it is one in my opinion this is why i
talked to carl actually because you get
so triggered about stuff on the left and
not on the right when i know you
disagree morally with so much stuff on
the right and i think the issue is well
it requires people to do something well
here's my take on it uh
and you know the and people said the
same to me it's like you know not left
not right it's like you seem to be
talking about
issues with the democratic party more
and it could be because i'm more
familiar with them yeah um but a lot of
it is this where if you have the simple
conflict or clash between hey we're the
establishment where the institutions we
know best and hey
you burn it down you are full of
then you're looking at it being
like well my natural impulse then is to
go to the people who represent the
institutions and be like okay like
here's
why why people are struggling here's why
people are pissed here's why they're
like they live in people yeah that
that's like a natural place to be
um the other place to be over here
with these folks um you know
you could urge i don't know like
patience
like you know like don't worry like they
will get their stuff together fellini
like converting white nationalists into
that's harder you're saying but but it's
not that illogical for you or me to look
at like these two signs and be like hey
institution x like maybe you could do
this but part of the issue is that
they're
not very introspective and here's one of
the reasons why i started the forward
party is that
uh is that when you realize that neither
victory
nor policy
is the true focus of
either party
then you get it
um so the democratic party will convey
the republican party will say like hey
where about you know this education
policy like this and then if you look up
and say okay like where are we on these
issues this is why these parents are so
pissed off they're like wait a minute i
thought you were for this it's like yeah
well you know we just wanted to win oh
no no we're we're for talking about it
but but we aren't but we don't actually
want to be held accountable for any
results and then if you try and hold us
accountable then we're like oh like
that's not what we're not about when you
realize that
they're not about either achieving their
goals or
uh even winning races
that's the the thing because you're
looking up and you see like why why did
we do things sometimes that
are definitely reducing our chances of
winning i mean oh because because the
point is not to win
you know if you go to someone and say
hey latinx turns out it pisses off 30 of
uh latinos and makes two percent of them
happy maybe we should abandon it um but
then they'll be like well that's not
right and you're like well
you know it's just math i mean like i if
your goal is to win then you would not
use this term and then be like oh but
you know it raises money by using the
term or you you keep my job by using the
term you have a particular like
ideological bent
um so when you realize that like the the
core is tribal
um which again these parents found out
the hard way which is like hey like i
thought the goals helped the kids i'm
like no no kids secondary um or tertiary
or i don't care because
all i want to do is
is uh feel good about my team
to me like the democrats are missing
kind of this like it's almost like the
hierarchy needs or like
like you have the right moral piece but
we're not nailing we're closing schools
we're missing that the streets aren't
safe we're missing crime right like uh
we're not solving
health healthcare ex whatever they are
but we've lost you you need to post
institutional wins on the board and the
institutional wins are very very hard to
to spot at this point do you think
infrastructure bill is something anyone
ever touts is something they
accomplished oh there's going to be a
lot of like crowing about the
infrastructure because it's one of the
only things they can point to they're
like you know by the way it's going to
take months if not years to like
actually see that roads you know yeah
roads will we actually see roads you
think
eventually you know it's like freaking
500 billion dollars plus so i mean there
it's it's gonna get spent
it's gonna get spent it's like the new
laguardia it'll take 15 years but then
it'll look good i love the new lagoon i
love the new laguardia i didn't love how
long it took it took a while yeah no i
agree um it is beautiful though if you
go to laguardia you're gonna be like
you'll
but i i i want to try and
uh dig into this point you're making
about you and your friend group and the
rest of it like this is
uh one of the reasons why i've started
forward and why the forward party is so
important and and i went through this
process the same as you did and we
learned a lot and got changed by it and
they're like uh you know the rest of it
we need to be a country where people are
not uh made to feel bad about themselves
based upon things they cannot control
about their own identity
you know i mean like
that should be the starting point
um now that's certainly true if you're
black gay
latino like you know any marginalized
group like you should not be made to
feel bad about yourself based upon who
you are
also true if you're a tall handsome
straight white man you should not be
made to feel bad about yourself based
upon i'm also like the boohoo straight
white guy get over yourself like you
know and i agree you know i see some of
that
based upon who you are um so the the
power differential narrative that john
and i'm so proud of my sit down with
john because i think it unpacks because
of john's genius like you know i was
just there
it's probably one of our best
best performing episodes for sure but
it's definitely one of our best quality
wise but that power differential
narrative that he framed as uh white
versus black um it's in everything now
it's
uh certainly male female straight gay
rich poor
um like the rich poor thing one of the
dynamics that's occurring now is that as
soon as
like an activist becomes successful and
have some money then everyone turns on
them because like oh now you're rich you
use the
xyz funds for your you bought a house
yeah like that they'll like uh attack
people on that level it's like bernie
but you you used to hammer the
millionaires and the billionaires and
now he just hammers the billionaires
because she's a millionaire yeah which i
don't have a problem with bernie making
money on
he's a warrior he's five other people
like yeah he's written a bunch of books
dude's 80-81 i mean no he's not that old
is he he might be yeah yeah hey siri how
old is bernie sanders 80.
yeah bernie's 80 years old yeah so for
an 80 year old who have crossed the
million dollar threshold i mean at 80.
yeah i don't think you should really
have a huge problem with that he's not
gonna then turn around and
[Laughter]
lose his way at 80.
[Music]
there is certainly truth to the fact
that society advantages certain types of
people and that
there's a lot of unfairness
um and you can accept that unfairness
without then projecting it onto the
character of any individual within the
system you can say like look this system
needs improvement i'd like to help
improve it my
frankly like most effective direct
suggestion would be to put money into
people's hands i think that that would
be the most uh powerful you know
like if you took the average struggling
black person you said hey i'm gonna give
you a choice on one hand give you a
thousand bucks on the other hand i'm
gonna get this uh white dude to
apologize to you
like which would they choose they all
choose a thousand but i say i don't give
a about this this person's
apologizing to me um especially if it's
a person i don't know you can want to
improve a system
without thinking anything negative about
the character of someone within that
system even if they've succeeded within
that system
because that person
and this is one of the biggest damaging
like things and someone will attack me
with this whatever
holding that individual accountable for
the system is just way too far a bridge
you know and and that's one of the
intellectual weaknesses of wokeness it's
like you're responsible you're complicit
you're culpable it's like that person
was born within a society and whatnot
like saying that they're responsible for
the society you know and again this is
someone who is very very aware of the
deep inequities like i understand just
how fundamentally screwed up a lot of
this has been and i do think that as a
society we should be trying to address
problems and make things better for
people as quickly as possible but i
don't think it's appropriate to point to
any individual within any group and say
like hey this is your fault like you
know this is you it's like because that
person will look at that and be and what
you're going to do is drive that person
away from whatever you're doing as
quickly as possible and if you do that
in mass
in
our country in this time you're going to
be driving
away
millions tens of millions of americans
that you're going to need it's one of
the things i struggle with so much
andrew with that
if you say the wrong thing or i say the
wrong thing not just on twitter in the
press
with your peers with other big
personalities that is taken in a vacuum
ignoring everything else about you that
would give that quote context
for example like you where you come from
son of immigrants like being an asian
man people called you a white
nationalist like absolutely okay but
then
like start taking
like your small earnings from a from
your first like your your first
successful uh
company sales starting a non-profit then
running for president on giving people
cash if you take me like starting a not
like i worked worked in philanthropy on
wall street have run a non-profit and
then worked on a long shot presidential
campaign to help eliminate poverty
those things matter when
you say the wrong thing if i say the
wrong phrase right and like by
any other objective measurement you're
an ally to trying to help the people
that we're talking about you're clearly
objectively one million percent an ally
trying to improve but that doesn't seem
to matter my question is can the dems
fix this i think the republicans
probably either don't give a or uh
but can the democrats fix this or is
literally the only possible solution
either ubi like mindset of abundance or
multiple political parties where we can
like not fix the problem but just like
troll each other and change the the
political way so this is the this is the
greatest hope we have and and it is in a
study that came out about the different
tribes and the the middle consists of
what's called the exhausted majority
where they're like oh
you know like i don't care about any of
this stuff i just want the like the
ideological nonsense
to go away um the the stuff we're
talking about with the obsession with
the power differential or whatnot it
applies to approximately 15
of people um which is a minority even
within the democratic party this
happened to be the the loudest and um
most conspicuous the same is true on the
other side where if you look at hardcore
trumpers and this is one reason why i
think characterizing all republicans as
racist is incorrect
uh you know all trump voters as uh as
immoral incorrect where you look at the
hardcore conservatives it's a similar
number it's about 15 percent interesting
the the problem really is that you have
a duopoly
where the republican party has no choice
but then i guess i'm voting for
this side and the democratic party it
has a different set of issues you have
this corporate establishment lair you
have
like an ideological left that that is
eager to call out people for
misstatements and and whatnot they're
different sets of issues yeah and i will
say that to the extent that i'm
concerned about any group in this
country
it's the far right
who believe that uh violence is
justified to the extent that there's
like a real
uh deadly threat um it again it's not
symmetrical like the deadly threat is
these violent extremist individuals who
by the way now that group it's not going
to be like an individual or
unfortunately it's like this in kuwait
group of
frankly
maybe even more like tens of millions
of americans who are sympathetic to this
idea in part because we're being set up
for this this clash in this duopoly
christian piccolini's work around trying
to de-radicalize folks in this space is
some of the most important we should be
pouring
a ton of energy and resources into it to
the extent that we do
degenerate into political violence will
almost certainly
originate with this group
it's one reason why you need to try and
carve up this duopoly as quickly as
possible because you have this exhausted
majority in the middle who then are
looking at it and saying like ah like i
don't really feel represented and then
they just go home and keep their mouth
shut if you had
a movement where people like that felt
like okay this is it this is my tribe i
can say i'm forward party and a critical
mass of people
are
able to see themselves represented in
this now the tough part is that the
folks who are quietly at home keeping
their heads down uh you know that
they're
right now reluctant to raise their hand
for just about anything yeah um
politically because they're you know
they they have lives and families and
like you know they they see the dynamic
that sprung up if we were to have a
genuinely multi-party system you would
have this middle force that would have a
ton of energy and weight in my ideal
structure and framework right now we'd
have five political parties yeah there'd
be the
uh the progressives uh the moderate dems
uh forward party kind of a as a fulcrum
moderate republicans and conservative
republicans like that and and then if
you had that you'd have a much more
coherent system and they would call out
the excesses
but right now they can't call out the
excesses because they see it as attack
on their team i love this as a solution
because it doesn't actually um
pretend that our media environment will
ever change in the sense that if a lot
of these parties they're like calling
card is just trolling the other team
which is very much what happens all the
time um yep
but if you have five of them they can
gang up on each other in a way you know
you know like oh the republicans do
something awful then the other four or
two or three of them can actually start
trolling the swing group would become
the moderate republicans because the
modern republicans like yo that stuff's
like crazy and out of bounds and they're
gonna be like oh you know like that that
that yeah you're the ones closer to the
fringes would become pretty powerful
because they would need that to get
because they would they bring them in
when they want them right um yeah and if
they don't agree then that doesn't
powerful it's a power more powerful of a
statement like actually we disagree
that's where we draw the line it's one
of the things about the democratic party
and parts of liberalism where i do think
you need to draw a line at certain parts
of like okay we can be pro teachers and
but at some point hey teacher you have
to go to work in the pandemic because
our kids are getting updated and not
dying yeah
the kids are the kids are getting well
i'm saying that because the data is like
it's
it's pretty safe for kids to go to
school the kids are losing losing years
of development right they're getting
stunted right like we don't we can
believe in being humane at our borders
but we actually should probably draw a
line and having a border because we're a
country and that's
what usually defines a country in many
ways if you really believed in
institutions in that space you'd be like
the school
being open for kids is mission critical
and vital and you know we have to make
that happen no matter what that's not
happening but i do so this does give me
um
a little insight into the purpose behind
the forward party too it's it's not just
this kind of general psyche or general
like zeitgeist it's like oh a third
party be good right like no it's
actually existential and it is
in part because if everything
degenerates into like oh you're
attacking my team
um then
civil war is inevitable right and to our
earlier point
you do not want to establish teams based
upon immutable identities you don't want
to say like hey
this party is for like this set of xyz
people that yeah yeah yeah
that that that'll kill you
oh man okay on a more positive note
you're watching nfl playoffs coming in
dude you're going to buffalo i'm going
for it is this the biggest game in your
memory
um i went to the afc championship last
year so i guess that's the bigger game
although we lost we're in kansas city
but this is the first time we've had a
home playoff game in buffalo since like
96. and you're going to be there to be
there it's going to be 10. playoff game
do it true fandom playing the patriots
so if you're a patriots fan listen to
this podcast
just don't give me some good juju i need
that good vibes i don't you guys have
had your he is going to buffalo in eight
degree weather to support his team awful
and if they lose
it's going to be a very sad gathering i
wasn't gonna go if it was on sunday you
know what i'm saying because i needed
like having like
sunday scaries or like a regular monday
work and that loss would be awful but
it's a saturday night game saturday
night prime time 8 15. i think
um so we'll see i think the look nfl
this is a fun nfl season because no one
knows who's going to win
i don't believe in the titans as the
number one season i don't think anyone
does right
who knows man i mean that you got to
give credit credits too they lost their
top two receivers and their star running
back and still won 12 games
um but like chiefs and the bills beat
themselves so they're good enough to win
super bowls if they actually
um play well the rest of that afc i mean
the bengals can beat most anybody too on
any given sunday um it's an interesting
season like you know you don't have a
heavyweight as i just said i don't
believe in the titans so you know it's
like you definitely
um what about on the other side
brady rogers seemed to be my
standard you feel like green bay is
going to come up through the nfc right
i mean ray's team is all banged up
they've lost a couple of key players um
and antonio brown lost his mind
i don't know
yeah
it doesn't feel like
the buccaneers have it
uh maybe it's because they had that bad
loss the other week
uh the saints i think was it yeah they
lost to someone they got a loss too oh
god it wasn't the jets was it i thought
it was the saints as the saints we're
not a bad loss i agree but i think um
i'm pumped because it's a exciting nfl
season and the bills are relevant in the
playoffs we've won back-to-back afc's
champions championships this is uh
uncharted territory for me as a fan it's
very exciting um
and for those of you who are georgia
fans or people who hate alabama
congratulations this week on your
national championship georgia i tweeted
i think this is true i don't know your
thoughts i think a
university of georgia university alabama
football game is like watching the
patriots cowboys play in a super bowl
uh in that no one
ugh
you mean that's too dumb no one likes
the
i don't know it just feels i i was
deliberately i'm wrong i was
deliberating on something and this is
just an
aside
i really really did not like the
patriots during the belichick brady era
and then brady leaving for the box
um
like now i find myself being like hey
did i dislike brady or did i just like
the patriots i still find myself
disliking the patriots
but but now i'm like
kind of
neutral on tom brady and the buccaneers
i really respect the fact he left and
won and is still doing his thing
it's amazing it is amazing and the
longevity and the rest of it like you
know it's funny it's like him leaving
the patriots now has made me like oh
like
because when he was with the patriots i
was like i can't stand those guys
then tom brady wins a super bowl wants
around the city kind of drunk in public
he was like pretty there's some memes on
tom brady it was hilarious um
yeah look i think the patriots i mean
the cheating allegations are rough um
now i realize between the two of them it
turns out i disliked belichick
yeah and uh you know brady now i'm i'm
fine with um so go bills this weekend
i'm uh as a duke basketball fan i've
seen like i finally feel both sides of
this equation right like duke is a very
hated basketball team people hate coach
k they'd love to hate and almost hate
the team in the country buffalo feels
like the nice underdog people story love
that yeah can't hate buffalo that's my
uh
my charming aspect my personality guys
i'm a bill's fan that's all i got
it is very charming so i had to have
something to fall back on
the devil incarnate of this
podcast uh you're welcome america this
is fun andrew this is good hopefully we
didn't say anything too bad we'll see
you next week folks
bye everyone
[Music]
you